-And now here he is,
Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ -Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
-What?!
♪ -Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness. Wow!
Is it real? Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is this really happening?!
Thank you very much!
Please, please, please.
Thank you very much.
Wow. Welcome, welcome,
welcome, everybody,
to "The Tonight Show!"
You guys, we are --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are finally back home
in Studio 6B.
It is so good...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...to see this beautiful set
and this crowd right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness.
And also the family of raccoons
that now live in my desk,
which is --
[ Laughter ]
Please, just give me a minute
to soak up this audience.
I've never been
so excited to do a show
for 58 people in my entire life.
This is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is what -- this is --
this is -- seriously!
Seriously, after --
[ Cheers and applause ]
After last year,
this is like performing
at a sold-out
Madison Square Garden.
It really feels that way.
It really does.
That's right. For the first time
in over a year,
we have an actual crowd.
So now if you hear total silence
after a joke,
that's just because
it wasn't good.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, all week, our audience
will include
first responders
and healthcare workers.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Everyone here is fully masked,
fully vaccinated,
and fully skipping work,
by the way.
[ Laughter ]
You deserve it.
Of course, I just want to thank
all of you for everything
you've done for this country
in the past year.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, everybody, let's start
the show with some fun news.
March Madness is in full swing,
and we're down to the Sweet 16.
And already, there are
zero perfect brackets left.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I can't believe
our strategy of five minutes
of research and blind guessing
didn't work.
[ Light laughter ]
Those are one of the jokes
that didn't work, guys.
[ Laughter ]
You'll be hearing them
throughout the evening.
-It's real, man. It's real.
-One of the biggest upsets
was number 8 Loyola Chicago
knocking off number 1 Illinois.
And no one's happier about it
than 101-year-old nun
and team chaplain Sister Jean.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She was psyched.
After the game,
Sister Jean was amped up.
In the locker room,
she was spraying holy water
like it was champagne.
[ Laughter ]
And during the broadcast,
they talked about Sister Jean's
pregame prayer that she
delivered to the team.
It's amazing. Listen to this.
-Here's what she told them.
"As we play the Fighting Illini,
we ask for special help
to overcome this team
and get a great win.
We hope to score early
and make our opponents nervous.
We have great opportunity
to convert rebounds as this team
makes about 50% of layups
and 30% of its 3-pointers.
Our defense can
take care of that."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Right now,
Charles Barkley is like,
"She's better at analyzing
college basketball than I am!"
[ Laughter ]
If you think that's shocking,
next season,
Sister Jean is being added to
the cast of "Basketball Wives."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the tournament's
true Cinderella
is Oral Roberts University.
They beat Ohio State
and Florida,
becoming just the second 15 seed
in history to make the Sweet 16.
Oral Roberts fans were like,
"Maybe now people will stop
thinking we're a toothpaste."
[ Laughter ]
Actually, "Oral Roberts" sounds
like something
you can't say around
Sister Jean.
[ Laughter ]
After Oral Roberts pulled off
their second huge upset,
the students back on campus
in Tulsa were pretty excited.
Take a look at this.
[ Cheering ]
-Enjoy it. Soak it in.
-Even spring breakers in Florida
were like,
"Everyone's pretty close.
Just saying."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, not only is it
March Madness,
it's also spring break season.
But over the weekend, Miami
declared a state of emergency
and mandated a curfew
due to COVID concerns.
You know things
are out of control
when Florida
is worried about COVID.
[ Laughter ]
College kids were like, "It's
a shame, 'cause I flew to Miami
during a pandemic
to party very responsibly."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, now there's a curfew
from 8:00 p.m. to 6:00 a.m.,
so spring breakers will have to
return to their motel rooms.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
The best way
to guard against COVID
is forcing drunks
into small, confined spaces.
That's what I've always heard.
[ Laughter ]
Some more news here.
Just when you thought
he was gone,
I saw that former
President Trump is creating
his own social-media platform.
If it goes according to plan,
it'll be the first thing
he'll help go viral
since the coronavirus.
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Applause ]
But you have to be careful with
the Trump social-media platform.
The site will automatically flag
any statements
that turn out to be factual.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, not to be outdone,
last week, Joe Biden joined
Tumblr on the stairs
of Air Force One.
Take a look at --
Whoop! There you go.
Oh, boy! Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
At that point, just lay there.
"I'm taking my Zoom meetings
from here."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Trump,
I just saw an update on
what's going on
with his old private plane.
Watch this.
-It was the ultimate
status symbol --
Donald Trump's Boeing 757.
Today, however, the massive jet
sits abandoned
at an upstate New York airport.
One engine mostly missing,
one wrapped, idle,
in apparent disrepair.
According to records,
it hasn't been flown in months.
-Yeah, one engine wrapped,
the other's missing.
Or as United put it,
"We'll take it!"
[ Laughter ]
"Get that baby in the sky!"
Some business news --
I saw that Krispy Kreme is
giving free glazed doughnuts
to customers who get vaccinated.
[ Audience oohs ]
I'd like to meet
the one person who's like,
"I wasn't gonna
get the vaccine, but...
[ Laughter ]
"...I heard about
that free doughnut."
[ Applause ]
"You pick the arm. I don't care.
I hold a doughnut with this arm.
So you gotta get --"
[ Laughter ]
So if obesity wasn't your
pre-existing condition before...
[ Laughter ]
...it's about to be.
I heard about a winery
in California
that's offering
a pretty sweet job.
Listen to this thing.
-The Murphy-Goode Winery
in Sonoma, California,
is offering $10,000 a month to
work and live there rent free.
The company is looking for
someone who
"takes life one sip at a time."
[ Laughter ]
-When they heard that,
every parent trying to
teach their kids on Zoom
was like...
[ Cheering ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Check this out.
A man in California is
being investigated for
using a drone to deliver meth.
Police got suspicious when they
saw the man 200 feet in the air,
hanging onto the drone.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a United flight
from Newark to Miami
was diverted after one man
bit another passenger's ear.
[ Audience oohs ]
When United heard,
they immediately charged him
$8 for an in-flight snack.